Euh, on on peut pas les giférer par l'anecdote,
c'est. C'est pas possible,
à moins de considérer toutes les personnes,
euh qui sont au RSA,
euh sont des gens qui ne veulent pas travailler,
euh, ce qui n'est pas le cas.
Euh, on peut pas les gifler par l'anecdote.
Et je voudrais,
je voudrais,
je voudrais lui rappeler que le discours qu'il dit,
quand on prend 1 exemple,
en disant
1 personne qui dit qu'elle ne veut pas travailler,
je le renverrai vers des études sociologiques
qui montrent que
chez les personnes qui sont loin de l'emploi
et qui sont abîmées par l'inactivité,
ces personnes, elles tiennent 1 discours de l'honneur,
c'est-à-dire que pour 1 centre de personnes,
c'est beaucoup plus facile
de dire, je ne veux pas travailler,
que d'admettre,
je suis en difficulté face au travail.
Donc
c'est pour ça que je dis que légiférer par l'anecdote,
c'est du populisme,
c'est du populisme, puisqu'il prend 1 exemple, 1 phrase
sortie d'un contexte,
sorti d'une situation sociale,
pour l'ériger comme 1 règle,
et les giférer autour de cette règle.
Et ça, c'est absolument pas acceptable,
absolument pas acceptable.